the recent rava fake news has reignited
the debate over what sources can and
can't be trusted in the digital age it's
a debate that is especially relevant in
the advertising industry not least with
advertisers want an assurances over
where their ad runs and who really sees
it will click Channel international it's
one of the world's largest outdoor
advertising companies and we lamech
O'Shea is its chairman and chief
executive so we're in good evening to
you now advertisers recently dropped
their campaigns with Google and Facebook
after their ads started popping up in
all sorts of unsavory places presumably
for a traditional advertiser like you on
Billboard's that plates your strengths
yeah I mean it's something that we
certainly feel very confident about in
terms of the fact that advertisers know
exactly where they're going to appear
and there isn't going to be any kind of
unsavory or uncomfortable content around
them like you know you might find on
YouTube so yes context is a very
important part of our cell I would say
so where does outdoor advertising fit
into this increasingly online universe
well we've been going through something
of a transformation we are the oldest
advertising medium of them all I mean
people have been sticking bits of paper
on walls for literary centuries but over
the last 10 years we have become part of
that digital advertising infrastructure
as more and more of our boards and
screens become digital and so we're now
part I think of a of a if you like an
ecosystem for advertising where you can
really choose when you appear where you
appear and choose what audience you
reach with much more accuracy than you
ever could before it's quite stronger I
mean when you go on the lift and the
elevators on the London the escalators
are on ya American on the London
Underground I mean you're you see
adverts popping up that see ya which
means that advertisers can be much more
specific with our medium than they used
to be able to about when they advertise
what time of day what day of the week
much more flexibility than we could ever
ever offer before and much more
precisely targeted to a particular
audience type than we were able to so I
think that is why we are growing faster
than any other advertising medium at all
at the moment yeah which is written on
mobile phones and well mobile and asked
are probably neck-and-neck in some
markets but we're now growing faster
than online and Internet advertising for
exactly the reasons that you stated I
think that you know some of the
surrounding them is pretty questionable
and I think some of the data that
advertisers were receiving also had been
fairly spurious as there's been a lot of
publicity around these these bots that
pretend to be real people but actually
are just a machine you know so yeah he
said you know who's seeing our ads so
what other markets neither where you're
actually making more money from digital
electronic display advertising than you
are from traditional posters yeah we've
just passed that point in the UK so in
the UK went out 55 to 60% of our
revenues are coming from those digital
screens and in other markets across
Europe we're rapidly getting to that
point so that that will you know that
Digital tipping point if you like is
becoming very important to us because
when you can offer advertisers a
national digital product you really can
change the conversation that we have
with them about you know what the
proposition is and when they want to
advertise and you able to charge more
for for that sort of advertising that's
the idea yeah basically we can we can we
you know we get better yield from each
screen so so we certainly are it's a
highly profitable opportunity for us I
would say and who's advertising the most
with you the most desert is a difference
if there is a difficult question I think
what's exciting for us about these
digital screens is that they are
bringing new advertisers who would never
have used our medium before so
advertisers who want to decide today
what they're going to put on a billboard
tomorrow
can use us in a way which was
inconceivable in the past where you know
used to have to plan literally months in
advance so that short term money that's
coming into the medium like for instance
we will have DIY stores advertising just
on a Friday and Saturday just before a
bank holiday weekend and then they
decide to do that literally days before
the ads appear so it's a very different
proposition than we've had before